[Musique]
car de pirate on vous entre ap après le
visionnement presse de bonjour bravo
c'est un film mettant en vedette les
artistes de votre nouvelle étiquette de
disques justement bravo musique
vous êtes un moment assez important pour
vous c'est quand même un grand jour pour
moi parce que je trouve un seul phone ne
faire jouer les artistes ensemble des
jeux 2 1 puis 2 2 je pense que on veut
soutenir la fin local on veut soutenir
la musique disciples pour moi c'est une
car deux autres que c'est une carte de
visite
incroyable pour le label wild 2 1 mais 2
2 ça va permettre aux gens de découvrir
la faune locale découvre la musique
locale qui est re découvre des artistes
qui émet des jeux annoncés chez
mécontente
comment ça se passe pour vous parce que
on connaît coeur de pirate l'artiste
mais maintenant le droit à coeur de
pirate la gestionnaire l'administratrice
et c'est sûr que l'on tombe dans
l'entrepreneuriat une maison 10 mais
c'est quelque chose que je faisais des
jeux en tant que coeur de pirate jérémy
budget je voyais ce qu'ils avaient à
faire je vais me la planification c'est
un peu ce que je fais le mépris qu'on y
cherche kang pourtant relativement
beaucoup aidé aussi fait que je peux
continuer à faire ma job de coeur de
pirate en parallèle mais jusqu'à présent
depuis le début de cette aventure je
fais ce mal à vous trouver le temps de
tout faire je me dis quoi je me sens
comme ok d'accord
plus de 100 fois que je pensais et parce
que ça c'est une forme d'adaptation pour
moi je mettrais dans un bus rouge j'ai
jamais faite sur mais honnêtement si
c'est l'fun qui j'aime beaucoup voir
comment ça fonctionne derrière les
coulisses chose qu'on hip hop contre
camp fait pas face à ce qu on est
artiste souvent on se rend pas compte de
tout le travail qu'il fait en armant qui
c'est super intéressant pour vous la
gestion c'est une affaire de famille
sans jeu de mots parce que votre père
est informaticien mais il vous a aidé en
quelque sorte
en fait mon père était à sa façon
gestionnaire vp finance ce qui fait
aujourd'hui avec nous il s'est occupé de
ma carrière depuis le début puis
puisqu'il faisait à l'époque quand je te
prie titre et qui achetaient des
compagnies qui les revendaient après
c'est comme son qu'il y est mais
vraiment ce genre de titre compte wehrli
à petite échelle le fait que je me
rappelle y avait un chien compagnie de
faire ce qu'il avait revendu à prêter
c'est comme ça qu'il ya des affaires
comme ça qu'ils étaient entre le monde
des enfants j'étais un petit peu de lui
et qui je les écoute encore aujourd'hui
mais c'est sûr que je trouve ce ça m'a
beaucoup aidé quand quant à
l'acquisition de la compagnie qui
aujourd'hui j'espère qu'enfin niveau
rester avec moi
et
il
sans flagornerie j'ai vraiment beaucoup
aimé votre votre nouvel album
instrumental perséides
je pense que c'est mon album préféré une
vous c'est très gentil c'était parce que
je chante au dessus ce qui se passe
quelque chose
vous l'avez senti que ça peut être mais
d'un petit virage pour vous là et je
pense qu'au niveau de la création ça m'a
permis de créer autrement parce qu'avant
je voyais vraiment piano comme genre de
béquilles le petit quelque chose qui
faisait juste ma compagnie qui
s'amorçait ajustements farocki comment
je me mets trop fort sur cet instrument
le qui m'ont aidé toute ma vie que j'ai
longtemps détesté parce que c'était une
obligation
et puis en fait non c'est comme si on
entendait chanter une chanson avec la
main droite par moments sur l'album
physique peut-être que ça va mais france
et par la suite des choses entre que
dans ma façon cris votre album perséides
c'est un hommage au québec parce que
c'est des petits tableaux de plusieurs
régions du québec
mais j'ai l'impression aussi que c'est
un hommage à votre mère qui est pianiste
enfin c'est un hommage à oui ma mère qui
est pianiste mon père aussi mais il part
elles m'ont traîné un peu partout dans
ces villes du québec quand j'étais plus
jeune je respectais pas mal à l'époque
parce que tu es quand j'ai porté de 12
entre pas vraiment envie de te baigner
genre est dans le fleuve le mais bon
c'est pas aux programmes j'étais
contente maintenant je suis pas contente
quitter aujourd'hui juge je voyais tout
le monde québec à bord du fon n'était
pas aussi aller découvrir le québec je
sais comme moi je connais toutes ces
endroits le fait que non c'est vraiment
ça me fait me permit de renouer avec ce
passé l'heure de rendre hommage à ma
mère aussi qui qui me mit ou qui en
outre il est jeune et puis aussi faire
voyager les gens je pense qu on a tous
besoin d'un peu de réconfort cette année
puis en quoi de mieux qu'un album de
musique instrumentale pour nous faire du
bien
ces deux sites
doublement est plus dur à faire
vous brillez l'international depuis
plusieurs années avec déconfinement
comment voyez la suite des choses pour
pour la tournée par exemple j'ai des
concerts de prévus
en europe le mandat ni la fin d'année
aux états unis fait que je vais y aller
parce que chaque mèche ma première dose
de vaccin qui fait que je vais avoir la
prochaine bulle et au fait que j'arrive
je m'en vais coeur de pirate merci
beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]